all right um when I do for example
Cho um H my energy and his energy is
permeating my body and then I am
internally redirecting it down to the
ground and that doesn't change once I
start the yin movement in the yin
yield so for example what I mean by that
is if I stop so here
he can't he can't push me over and a a
lot of more people can do that but it's
done cosmetically or externally and that
I have a bracing angle which will be
evident if he lets go
quickly whereas if it's passing through
me is the energy is going down so when
he lets go there's no flow that way it
comes up
okay so it's not skill alignment and
bracing angle even as I go to the yin
motion which has no skeletal alignment
okay this energy is going down to the
ground Vector so maybe you're over here
and you can see if he pushes this this
should not be possible from an external
materialist point of view but energy can
do this so even as I'm going to the
yield you you could he get his posture
if he wanted to and he's trying to push
that way it's still relaxed he still
can't do it so as I go he's clearly not
at the same
angle as I do each increment in the
rotation which means that I cannot
keep the same ground
vectoring throughout the one that is
here is constantly changing internally
for every time he changes what he's
doing every
time and
that is one way of understanding this
meaning if you do this and you have a
skeletal alignment and you just
have tension which gets renamed
as
extension you're going to now lose that
as you go into that
yield meaning you will not be able to
keep the structural Integrity once you
come outside of that oppositional angle
okay so I'm one way of looking at it is
I am
constantly allowing the energy to change
according to the change of the technique
but giving it at the same
destination another way of looking at it
is that I am I have become
permeable okay and it doesn't matter
where what angle his energy is at it
doesn't it's not that I'm consciously
continually
Shifting the
pinball little bumpers in my body to do
it it's more that I become just per able
okay so for example um we've we've
demonstrated this before so here here is
that weird angle but if you
got he'll take this angle so camera has
to come over
here it's say it's not going to be like
whoa how do I balance these two I I am
in that same permeability ground vectory
it doesn't it doesn't matter
even if he takes the same angle Noe here
on this here you see that it's not going
to whoa whoa It's not that I'm doing
anything different I I have the same
permeability you understand that and I
and remember this is all Poetics
meaning you're trying to put in words
what is
not
binary and dichotomous but language
binary and dichotomous okay so it's all
Poetics it's just just pointers okay so
you could
see the idea of incrementally adapting
kind of made sense to the dichot in the
spine but when you have another angle
how the heck are you micro adjusting
materially inside for the multiple
angles do you see that it's that's not
really what's happening I I am permeable
is what is happening okay I have become
permeable all energy pass is passing
through me
okay does that make sense in some weird
way so going back to having shman subti
be an internal training drill again
I take my
mask and I Vector it to the
midfoot again that's a poetic that's
upaya it's not actually what's happening
but it'll get
you there it what how it'll stop you
doing stuff like this you see that this
is this is heal weighty and that's going
to be very difficult for the beginner to
do you can do it because it doesn't
matter
this doesn't materially it does not
matter but as a
Gateway you don't want to start at the
end you don't you don't want to learn to
swim in the deep end in other words okay
try to set yourself up for Success so my
weight I become permeable with my energy
and my marker is midot weight now I'm
going to add the book in the book in
it's going to add more energy and you
can see it's out there so for
example if I become permeable to my
body and with the goal of midfoot
vectoring when you put this out if you
keep that exact thing you start to go
forward you
see and I would not look at my feet
right now I would I would look
at the geometry of my body to the ground
so I would look at my side as much as
possible
okay it's not going to be magic in your
feet or magic in your
hands it's
allowing
Gravity the energy of my own matter to
pass through me and now it's the same
thing same exact thing you're going to
have to make some microchips and and
guess what as you go through the cut you
have to do the same
thing because that is constantly
changing the center of gravity do you
understand
that
well is it a matter that I'm making
these micro adjustments as I'm going no
I would say no it's a matter that I'm
permeable okay it's a matter that I'm
permeable
so what I want you to do in this next
exercise is look at showman sub
booty from the point of
view of are you keeping the ground
Vector throughout the movement or is it
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth you understand as opposed to
up and down up and down
up and down okay let's try that
real so going back to something said in
one is that I am not trying to get
stronger if you want to get stronger
lift weights okay so it's not an arm
exercise and it's not a leg exercise so
I'm not trying to work my
quadriceps you want stronger legs squat
Dead lip right you want that performance
output and
therefore it also doesn't matter or
let's
say the heavier subito is not more
relevant in regards to strength
right it's going to increase the energy
at which I'm operating at and therefore
be more of a window into how permeable I
am okay so for
example
um if someone
is
and if Priscilla is here if I am only
somewhat semi-
permeable uh and she's trying to push me
over I you kind of uh game it I'm
have a little flexion I'm holding
flexion in my leg and it'll kind of work
you
see you get someone stronger you
increase the amount of energy and it'll
expose that it's not working okay
likewise when I had two people pushing
at different vectors it's going to be
more telling whether I'm permeable or
not okay so for example rain will come
out and uh say there over here and
you're going to push on
her and so the energy that is passing
through ground ground ground do you see
it
can appear to be
functioning okay and now we'll put more
pressure and we'll have a increased
pressure which you can do by somebody
that is stronger and you're going to see
that it it was not functioning at all or
if we do do the other drill right and
you're going to do tyo henko slowly so
let you're going to come to this angle
and she's going to
get this clearly not skeletal alignment
more over here right you see he's
passing through her you see that and so
it'll expose how much of the previous
angle was skeletal alignment was
material was external how much was
internal so go like this and just
push youing
or we do the other one get to there
stop right give me your other hand and
I'll take this angle and will you can
see that she's not grounded at all she's
not rooted at all do you understand okay
so as you increase the pressure it is
more telling of how permanent
you are okay and that's what a heavier
subb toe
does it's more like a a truth stick okay
but you don't want to get a heavier uh
spab toe to uh condition yourself that's
not the point and likewise you don't
need this to go there you can of course
you can ground Vector here as
well but the
drill is the
okay so let's try it with suby toe
now okay so as the beginner Gateway all
that energy is I'm going to focus it uh
or at least observe that it is at the
midfoot vector okay and again in more
accurate Poetics that me micro adjust
tting my balance so that energy is going
down there is more that I become
permeable and then energy does its thing
what's its thing it fills vacuums and it
drops it will drop it's heavy it goes
down okay and then I am intellectually
confirming that it's going down by using
my mind uh to register midfoot okay so
as I'm doing the move
I have made myself permeable that is the
skill of releasing okay that is the uh
the religious skill the spiritual skill
that you're trying to cultivate in your
training is the skill of releasing is
the skill of becoming permeable okay
becoming permeable to what to immaterial
things okay in this case
energy in other cases the Divine I
become
permeable creates a
vacuum that
immaterial energy comes into my being so
in O sensei's practice he would do
various techniques to become permeable
he developed the skill of releasing he
became permeable and the commi would go
into
him we're same thing it's a concentric
Arc the Kami is IM material gravity
inertia friction immaterial same thing
it comes into
me I under the same laws okay
so I become permeable and what I'm going
to do is the same thing that I
do in a c
projection so I'm grounding here and
when I want to to I take the energy that
is there and I bounce it and allow it to
come back up the vacuum that I created
and into
him so as I move there's going to be a
left
hand projection right here on the end of
the Suka so that energy coming down
my body coming down the weapon coming
down boom all that is being passed
through my body to the ground vector and
at the exact moment of it coming
underneath at parallel to the
ground under or where my H
is that's where I poke you the left
hand you'll see the tip wants to come up
boom boom
it's not that I use the right hand to
slow the sword
down and stop
it I let it go all the way
down left
hand is on top and boom hits that part
boom
boom so you see the same kind of I'm I'm
exaggerating it now just like in that PO
projection I'm
exaggerating this kind of bouncing this
kind of rebounding so you can see it
okay this hand is
loose and it's not on my fingers it's on
my heel on the the heel Palm it's on top
boom and you're going to have that
little rebounding in my body
boom when you're bounces
up my grip now blends with the raising
of the sword so I don't lift the sword
just like I don't slow the
sword I don't lift the
sword I follow the sword
up so
I have zero pressure on the spoken after
the C meaning I'm not
positive but I'm not negative either and
I'm not trying to bring the sword up
mechanically this way that's
Leverage leverage I'm trying to stack
the weight and then bring it up I'm not
doing
that I follow it up boom follow it
up if I just stop you the weapon will go
behind
so as I I adhere to the weapon up
neither pushing nor pulling just blend
in with it it's going to come
up and at this point you're going to
feel the other CQ location you're will
be in the right hand and you're going to
see you're going to experience another
one of those profession bounces or
rebounding So you you're going to see
like a double I'll exag you're going to
see like a double bounce not just the
one where I come down you see this I
just come down this is leg
training this one boom there it is pop
pop pop pop pop right hand left hand
it's not that they're pushing and
pulling on each
other you see it at the top again
another re another rebounding another
percussion okay let's
try Hey so uh
common
misunderstandings you coordinate
inhalation uh with Yin and exhalation
with Y and so
um and then the colonist understanding
is that uh movement M up all the way to
up is going to
begin and then movement down all the way
down is y so you
inhale on the way up and then exhale no
the the CQ requires in the beginner the
C is the exhalation so you have up at
the
top you have another one in the
hand
and then one at the bottom
so not like
that
okay now
beate you are counter
rotating the hands against each other so
usually you'll do that in the beginning
to get a mechanical advantage
here you stack the bul
in but here you see it too you pull the
hand you pull the left
hand well I'm not pulling the left hand
because the left hand is in an nely
state so it doesn't generate more
energy it stays neutral at zero the left
hand is what sends I'm sorry the right
hand is what sends the book
not the left hand pulling against the
right hand
okay
um let's define terms a little
bit so the
CQ is the pressurized vacuum resulting
of you becoming
permeable so as I become
permeable
energy creates this pressurized vacuum
inside or energy fills the vacuum of my
cavity my material body okay that's
C when I project with it to create
things rebounding that's me using C to
rebound
Okay C
you in other words you you can develop
coku here as I become permeable my body
will start to become pressurized this is
kokuo this is kokuo every step I take to
the UK I take myself become perable my
own energy of my own materiality goes
down into mat as I walk that is
couole offer that gets
pressurized that is all
Co
so that is what you're trying
for you are not
trying for muscular
strength grip strength shoulder strength
arm strength leg strength it's the
pressurized and then the utilization of
it in the projection points so I don't
want
to create a
flexion anywhere in my body because the
flexion creates an obstacle to my
permeability so I'm not trying to
twist that's generating pressure or
tension same thing here I'm not trying
to come
up I'm not trying to twer like that you
see
that I'm not
I'm not doing that that's not
Co body is relaxed projected to two
points two points there's the top
one boom boom and the bottom
one okay got it all right try
see you're just working
it okay let's pick it up you'll find it
more challenging why cuz more energy
okay try it again